there is a massive controversy going on
right now and in the middle is Suraj
revolved prominent youtuber so today
I'll just be actually shortly reporting
on this not giving too much opinion just
kind of um stating what's up in a very
high-level overview because if you
haven't heard of this I think it's
important that you do and this is both
sad and funny to a degree more sad
actually but you know make your own
opinions so serologist is very prominent
youtuber that makes videos mostly let's
say coding tutorials or explaining short
concepts in the field of machine
learning and recently also branched out
into other fields like like here watch
me build a marketing startup and so on
so what happened it was two recent
developments first of all he offered a
course and the course was two hundred
dollars and this is a one of his
students on Twitter and many more have
come out and he offered this course for
$200 and basically said make money with
machine learning that was the course and
he said he will going he was going to
take 500 students in this course and it
would be personalized learning
personalized support from basically from
him or he said he is all in into this
course then the students discovered that
there were actually over a thousand
people in the course and there was
always almost no personalized support so
there's only he was what giving 50
minutes of which is weekly time to do
Q&A 30 minutes of video content and they
apparently also replied to all the code
submissions with the exact same
so things like this
he actually split up the students into
two different slack groups so they
wouldn't notice that there are over a
thousand people so about two five
hundred people groups then people wanted
to wanted a refund and then apparently
when he hid the slack limit he
transferred them to discord and he had
it everyone that wanted a refund to
discord shuttle and then simply banned
them I mean that yeah but and there are
many more stories of students about this
course apparently this was this was kind
of really a bit of a scam this course
without especially that the refunds
there was no refund policy and then
about two weeks I think into the course
there was a refund policy so after two
weeks after the course started and the
refund policy said you can get a refund
within two weeks of the course starting
and so this I mean this is all just kind
of really really weird and I encourage
you to read up more on this because
there are many more father like stories
about this course so he apologized
publicly and said he shouldn't have done
that he should have hired TAS and so on
that that so you apologized for it and
that seemed to be kind of the end of
that I don't exactly know what happened
to the students some claims they never
got a refund and so on but then it went
on and it went on badly for Suraj if I
may say because he published a paper
called the neural cubed and people have
gone and it turns out that it is almost
all plagiarized from one or two other
papers actually
yeah it turns out it's it's I think it's
two papers and it's almost all
plagiarized from there and you can see
on the left the green sections and on
the right the red sections are exactly
identical for example this table up here
I think it's on the next page of the
other paper is exactly this from the
other paper if you look at whatever
these equations they're all the same the
sentences are exactly the same and so on
he only changed like that also the dick
diagrams you see her on the upper left
exactly taken from this other paper and
I think he mentions this other paper
cites it once and he says his work is
kind of a derivative of that or leaned
on that and so on but these aren't
explicitly quotes here the only changes
he made or changed his like so whenever
the other paper says we can write the
combined transformation here you can see
he says I can write and thanks to the CV
encoding I get a non linear functional I
mean there's a rule in computer science
the only person who's allowed to do this
is Don Knuth no one else that's I mean
that's wholly rule broken okay so more
seriously he changed that and then he
also kind of used a couple of synonyms
which may make no sense so for example
he replaced the word gate by the word
door and of course a logic gate it
becomes a logic door so here it's a
non-gaussian gate phi and i don't know
if in this instance but in this instance
he replaced it was it oh no here it
actually says gate but sometimes it's
replaced by PI door and also he replaced
the word complex Hilbert space too
complicated Hilbert space which makes no
sense at all so this uh yeah it's it
kind it's funny and sad at the same time
so so this this
and again he's apologizing this is icing
claims that mineral cubed favorites
partly plagiarized this is true and he
basically claims it he sort of blames it
he says he's doing too many videos a
week which I agree I mean I can I can
tell you that making videos is hard even
crappy videos like mine and his are
actually edited and so on but they the
problem is many people more came out and
said that he did the same thing to their
project here you see someone he did
exact same thing to our project it took
four people a couple of months due he
acted like it was his own and many more
came out and said he plagiarized other
he plagiarized other things as well
where he basically just takes code and
gives minimal or no attribution to the
original authors and then passed it off
as his his own this this after this
course yeah everyone this could not get
any worse
Suraj oh my gosh quantum doors yeah so
so this this all happened I mean I
encourage you go read up on it to make
up your own mind I don't just want to
point out quickly the end and I won't
actually show the the identity of the
person I'm posting this if you really
want to find out but it's not about that
person it's about the kind of sentiment
so there is a sentiment around that you
should kind of unfollow him and because
that lends credibility to him and there
is a point to be made of that kind of if
if the kind of prominent researchers
refer to him and so on that gives him
some credibility but I'm also very much
against sort of cancel culture it is
also the case that he know like no
matter how much is plagiarized has
popularized the field more than anyone
else and me
maybe you know there is a conversation
to be had and a lesson to be learned
without immediately canceling someone
that's just so that I mean there's it's
a complicated issue but just kind of
want to get this out there so go read up
on this is all it's it's yeah it's a
wild world so that being said but I have
found